and while the Attorney General bar
searches for truth and justice while the
Democrats on Capitol Hill predictably
busy wasting your time other people's
money still advancing a hoax still
advancing lies and conspiracy theories
for example Jerry Nadler is now
demanding the Attorney General revealed
grand jury information in the Muller
report Nadler actually wants the
Attorney General of the United States to
commit a crime or is going to be
handcuffed by the sergeant of arms
really as law professor Jonathan Turley
has pointed out it is Nadler who was in
for a world of hurt if he continues this
watch this I believe that the contempt
action of this committee was unfounded
but I also believe that if it goes to a
federal court this is another area where
I think that this committee could lose
when senators and it asked me why won't
he commit to releasing the full non
redacted report and I said because that
would be a crime you are heading into a
world are hurt if you go to the DC
Circuit and argue that you could order
bar that bar could unilaterally release
rule 60 information now now those
fishing expedition is going nowhere but
in an effort to be transparent as
possible Barr has expanded access to
most unredacted the most unredacted
version of the Muller report so that
Democrats if they just take the time
they can see almost all of it no word by
the way if any Democrats will bother to
take the time to look one sentence and
seven partial sentences removed
everything else remains and meanwhile as
we just heard bars legitimate
investigation into the deep state is
well underway so is the Horowitz probe
into FISA abuse and the Hoover report
investigating leaking and just this week
we learned about the John Durham
investigation into the origins of the
Russia probe the once powerful
high-ranking members of this deep state
that we have been talking about and
exposing for two years they are tonight
all running scared and they are now
turning on each other as we reported
last night Lisa Paige Peter struck
they're putting all the blame right on
that Attorney General lower
Lynch Comey is trashing struck in Page
on national TV rod Rosen Stein's being
trashed by James Comey and he's now
trashing back there both attacking each
other's character and of course this
brennan and call me they're blaming each
other for promoting and pushing the
dirty Clinton bought and paid for
Russian dossier and commis general
counsel James Baker just revealed that
he was quote quite worried that his boss
director called me of the FBI was
literally blackmailing Donald Trump with
Hillary's dirty Russian dossier you
couldn't put this in a spy novel but
it's all true okay so take a listen
the Hoover days especially the
investigation of Martin Luther King jr.
what was done there I know what you've
used behind what the word is the
blackmailing of dr. Martin Luther King
and so yeah we were quite worried about
that quite worried about how that would
come off and so we wanted to try to make
sure to convey to the president-elect
that that's what we were not doing that
sir we have this information it came to
us in a particular way the press has it
it's about to come out you should be
alerted to that fact we don't want to
proceed on this basis without you being
aware of those facts but no we were
quite worried about the the Hoover
analogies and were determined not to
have such a disaster happen on our watch
now we've warned Jimbo it's not a good
look when your own General Counsel is
comparing you to J Edgar Hoover of
course the FBI chief who was famous for
abusing power spying on Americans and
yes blackmailing his political
adversaries well while Baker expressed
concern over how Comey was using the
dossier he also claimed that the FBI
took the dossier seriously but not
literally really because that was the
bulk of information in the FISA
applications so sounds like they took it
literally take a look the information
came in and there was a lot of detail
with respect to a lot of different types
of activities that were allegedly going
on and so I guess the way I have phrased
that I think we took it seriously we
didn't necessarily
take it literally that was literally
true in every respect but it was
something that something that we were
obligated to deal with and obligated to
assess given what what we understood
what I understood to be the source of
the information
Christopher Steele at that point in time
we were obligated to take it seriously
and look at it and try to figure out
whether it wasn't true or not hold on a
second
if he didn't take the Hillary bought and
paid for Russian dossier seriously or
literally then why did James call me in
October of 2016
swear it says at the top of a FISA
application verified why did he swear
that the contents were true and accurate
in the first FISA requests why was that
request mark verified at the very top
now to James Comey lie then or did he
lie in January 2017 when he said to then
president-elect Trump it's salacious but
not verified he is at the very center of
what was a multi-year effort by the most
powerful unelected bureaucrats clearly
first to rig an investigation into their
favorite candidate when the evidence was
overwhelming and incontrovertible
Hillary Clinton the Espionage Act
Hillary Clinton obstruction of justice
the intent was clear destroyed the
evidence and that's why he delete 33,000
subpoenaed emails that's why you use
bleach fit that's why you'd have an aide
take a hammer and bust up all your
devices and remove all the SIM cards
that would be intent something they
tried to pin on Donald Trump when though
when there was no underlying crime four
investigations including the Mullen
report no collusion by the way it's over